there's more well--there's they're
different okay okay oh my goodness there
you go you can read that all right man
21 is arrested for coughing in a Chicago
cops face the faces and claiming he had
coronavirus after he got into the car
crash what we're in your right mind do
you think that you're not they're not
gonna arrest you or shoot you like a
czar there's right in his face like what
do you think they're gonna they're gonna
throw you down man he was driving on the
wrong side of the road okay look at his
face well he probably got tased yeah
he's like I can't believe I did that
he's an idiot his last name is Ponzi oh
my hmm related to the late Charles Ponzi
it wasn't a very good scheme they say he
was he was driving as bad he was driving
his great gray Jeep the wrong way on
Walcott Avenue and collided into another
car whoa well that's what happens it the
vehicle and allegedly attacked the other
driver are you serious what dude you
know man is going on that's the end the
world maybe he did have coronavirus it's
a new strain that's causing people to be
a little more zombie like oh and it's
not actually that guy in China who bit
the yeah I'm talking about
so we ignored that yeah maybe it's a new
strain Korona by KO vid 20 yeah it was
kovin 19 now it's pivot 20 they're
upgrading there's one more oh I'm
laughing but I really don't want to
believe it no so this one's this one's
the least bad of all of them New Jersey
woman charged with falsely telling
police she had the coronavirus hmm and
New Jersey man all right so new New
Jersey woman was charged with falsely
telling police she had coronavirus and
attempting to pass it to officers police
said Tuesday
this woman 28 purposefully coughed and
breathed on police as they processed her
arrest on March 12th wait so what was
she arrested for something different she
was driving alone toxicated oh okay just
like the guy yeah he's arrested her
after she was involved in a one car
crash while allegedly driving
intoxicated Hanover Township police
captain Dave white told the hill in
statement white said that PA
became belligerent while being
questioned by the officers on scene and
started breathing on one officer even
though he ordered her to stop i order
you to stop stop breathing on me man
stop breathing on me that is pretty
gross don't breathe on me at the station
she continued before reportedly saying
oh by the way I have the coronavirus and
so now you do - do you think they're
gonna do the world away - that what why
would you ever end tag there there is a
bit ever understood this how do you say
it properly schadenfreude joy and
someone else's downfall I know but it's
literally another own downfall oh no not
this one I got one more oh are you
serious is more well this one's not
really surprised after so after seeing
all these stories of kids licking
toilets and stuff like that you know
like I was saying okay the guy's trying
to be a loser on purpose yeah yeah the
toilet girl was just a loser in general
yeah it really none of them got the
coronavirus we presume Yeah right but
what if a bunch of morons went out and
partied when they said hey there's an
outbreak of this you know what interest
disease and then they got sick Oh what
if well apparently that happened
oh my Florida College students test
positive for a corona virus after going
on spring break our college student said
why would you go on spring break they
were told not to do it these are the
people that were doing drinking beer to
be chose butt cracks yeah okay I don't
feel bad from I got nothing yeah no III
don't feel bad for them go bad for the
hospitals yeah because guess what or
their families yeah cuz their families
you know who knows dude they're gonna
get everyone else sick it's like they
dude that Gobert do remember that guy
yeah and he was like I'm gonna touch
everything cuz all the mics
yeah yeah I'm good ha ha y'all think
it's funny but it's not now I have
coronavirus maybe maybe we deserve the
locusts well I'm not here yet I'm
staying I've been staying home like a
good good good point citizen I was gonna
say a good citizen but sure a good boy
good way yeah so these kids went out and
partied
here's the worst part of it we I was
reading an article earlier from Vox they
interviewed a guy from Moody's he's
analytics they they were the ones who
have this historically AK
here at presidential prediction model
based on the economy and they said we
are facing something that's akin or
worse to the Great Depression something
like that I don't know I'm paraphrasing
but but when you look at the amount of
unemployment claims it's a really
fascinating story because basically the
guy says is when it came to the Great
Depression people wanted to work they
were willing to work some were working
many were able but there was a credit
problem the flow of currency to make the
system work was busted and so then
people started panicking they don't want
to buy stuff that started saving so they
needed a stimulus to get people to feel
like they could spend again have
confidence and to get the machine start
churning so they thought the government
could step in make these purchases
confidently because they had nothing to
worry about
big attacks us and take whatever money
for whatever the money right and now get
the Machine going so what the article
said was that they didn't do enough they
didn't put enough into the stimulus so
it was a slow grind and they said there
was bickering between the parties the
problem the problem right now no one can
work nobody wants to talked about it
though no no about it in the economy
right now unemployment is was was wiped
clean it was like lowest in 65 years
before this happen right yeah and so
what happens right now we have the the
biggest workforce ready and willing and
completely unable to work true that's
why that's why this is so mind-numbing
if we don't get the economy back going
again going again soon mm-hmm it will be
bedlam like you won't even realize these
businesses will the businesses won't
exist anymore yeah and you'll have a
hole all of Manhattan will be empty
storefronts yeah cuz in in two or three
months these people have walked away and
then all the spoons all the food is
spoiled there's nothing left the
frigerators gotta be like it's what
spoons spoons foiled
yes so all the food spoiled you walk
back into these bodegas and what's there
you might have some product that can
last but a couple months there's a lot
of foods gone yeah they're gonna clean
it out all the machines got to be
cleaned employees are gone some people
might move on to what we get go home
dude if you live in Manhattan you know
the job for two months yeah you move
back home that's true are you gonna come
back to New York some people won't
probably now those companies might say
like I need an employee and they can't
find anybody so it literally just ends
after a certain point we can only stand
still for so long so because of these
people morons who are going around you
know pouring beer down the butt cracks
of other people in drinking it and
looking toilet seats
this is extending the the lockdown yeah
well they're taking up ventilators -
yeah dude blood man if you wanna IIIi
got a deal here's my bargain alright if
you want to drink beer out of the butt
crack of another person someone called
it a but a bunch of I thought that was
hilarious by the way you do you do you
think man hey hey whoa whoa whoa but
Chuck yeah in fact I'll tell you what
I'll buy you the beer what but that
means if you happy if you get the
coronavirus you can't go you can't get a
ventilator sure you have you wanted to
but chug alright nobody made you do it
no but of course we have to give a
ventilator you can't leave someone to
die you know what I mean that's it so
frustrating it's like that it's like the
health care thing with fat people yeah
it's like dude I would love universal
health care yeah but these other people
are completely overweight yeah and then
like you know man and you're not trying
to get healthier no I'm gonna stop right
there oh you're gonna stop I'm gonna
stop sure I will I will
at this point gladly accept paying for
universal have their taxes for all the
fat people you know why why but I will I
will not pay for the but chuggers the
blood sugar the blood sugars are the
line for me line we're Americans all
right we got cheap food we eat too much
and you know what I'm willing to accept
the obese people in the hospitals but
not the buggers all right you're right
coronaviruses changed things
dude there's there's a video from CBS
where these spring breakers mm-hmm they
purposefully go to the beach and they're
being filmed laughing oh dude one one
guys like I've been waiting too long for
this to let a corona you know take away
my Miami and I'm like bro do you have
any idea what's going on a corona do you
think we're talking about the beer yeah
I bet they do yeah seriously are you
concerned about the corona the beer
would immediately can I pour it on
someone's butt and drink it there was a
there was a woman in a woman at Saint
Patrick's to first you line it line the
edges the crack with a lime well it was
like a it was like a human centipede no
no it was like it
it was like Human Centipede her of they
all they all lined up behind each others
butts bent over and poured the drink
down the cracks and I'm for it's for
real it's what they did I mean I believe
you it does there was a there was a and
I think it was like the girls had no
problem about checking off girls but the
guys all wanted about check off the
girls so there was a one woman insane it
was a st. Patrick's Day thing in Chicago
and she was like I'm in she was being
interviewed by local news and she got
her arms around two guys I'm like that
and she's like I'm immuno compromised by
take supplement so it's okay like oh man
we gotta give route do we gotta give
these people ventilators cuz I don't
know man
I might actually prefer the 85 year old
you know Greatest Generation you love
them mister you got two months left to
live we're giving you the ventilator
she's got 80
I'm kidding by the way these are this
toilet girl apparently said I hate old
people that's why I did it there was
some twitch streamer and she said I hate
poor people or something she got banned
from twitch for saying that yeah so I'll
be I'll be you know I don't people take
stuff out of context but I mean in all
seriousness you know if somebody gets
sick they go to the hospital we're not
gonna leave any ones but it's just
frustrating that we are out all now
gonna suffer because they're really dumb
people who do these things and don't
take this stuff seriously yeah
yeah we got an 8 p.m. curfew for pete's
sake we're lucky right now but a couple
people in New Jersey already got
arrested for having people over they had
a couple dozen people had to get
together that's right in their backyard
and the neighbors called the cops and
the cops arrested them for a public
nuisance most a bunch of neighbors call
the cops yeah and there were there were
other there's other stuff too or
apparently some people tried calling the
cops on a Jewish wedding ceremony
because they were doing in their
backyard or something okay and that one
was more complicated because they were
like it's a religious ceremony the cops
parently came and broke it up or
something I don't know exactly what
happened but uh that's rough no but
we're gonna we're getting to that point
where people are start people getting
arrested yeah and and so what the
governor of New Jersey said is it
strongly recommended curfew
we could go outside right now no one
cares yeah like I went and danced in the
street for fun nobody cares of course
not like there's anyone around here
right and people are going to the store
like normal they're walking their dogs
to see people jogging well that's that's
in the rules like
okay hard quarantine unless you go
outside and exercise or well your animal
or go to the store for food or go to the
doctor or there's a few other things on
listen it's like okay if you go about
your day normally you know but don't go
out and have like you can't go to parlor
the piercing shop yeah don't don't go
you hear game stop claimed they were
essentially yeah yeah well they're
closing down Oh
during will be yeah end of the world I
would think so they actually told their
employees to ignore the police say if
the police come show them this letter
and it was a letter from corporate
saying what we told everyone to stay
open call our corporate office oh yeah
all the places gamestyle have no they
don't have stuff like that yeah people
download game or buy their game systems
online if they you know most people want
to save money that's where you get it
the cheapest right I go to Game Stop and
I walk around look at stuff and I say oh
I'll download that later and I leave
yeah they're not essential to anybody's
life yeah my discs on my first
PlayStation 4 stopped working so I just
started downloading it anyway and it
just makes things so much easier Game
Stop could have no door and it could
literally just be a glass single pane
and you to look through and be like okay
and you go back and you order any dolls
or gadgets on Amazon yeah you download
your games you don't it's it's it's only
a matter of time before they go out of
business
yeah but anyway back to the morons who
are talking to stuff anything with this
well trumps basically saying now that we
might lift quarantine early yeah he said
at first at 15 days and we would
reassess mmm because he's eager to get
things moving again yeah and some
there's been some people who have had
the idea that maybe we should just
quarantine we should isolate people who
are vulnerable and let young people and
people who have already recovered get
back to work
okay maybe because the young people can
handle it I guess is out there right
because the young people get sick tend
to be okay and they don't really need
ventilators or what they do we do less
likely to right no no they're more
likely be hospitalized and there they
respond better to ventilation so they're
more likely to survive yeah so anyway
that's the that's the deal I guess the
the issue is that
if the economy doesn't kick back on then
breaking on the economy is worse than
the actual disease because people gonna
die anyway yeah without without water
the hospitals are already strained for
constrained for cash and resources okay
so we're on the verge of what did Luke
call it he called it communism free
trial a 30-day free trial communism yeah
and he was like the problem is that once
you accept that free trial it's
impossible to cancel yeah and that's
exactly how it works yeah so this is
scary because right now what the
government's gonna have to bail out
hospitals they're gonna have to come in
there's already been conversations that
if the government provides a stimulus to
these big corporations that they're
buying stock in the corporations and
then the government is gonna have a
finger and a lot of these big companies
and we're getting dangerously close yeah
because then once the government has it
they don't let go right and you'll get
to that point where then all of a sudden
your plane is regulated by a bureaucrat
and we have to actually wait until they
die off because there's no term limits
for some reason well know that the
government grip and the government
government services don't stop ever no
matter how awful they are unless they
all change it you think they're gonna
know I don't either because they have
the power
well here's what'll happen they'll
create you know the federal
transportation you know arm or whatever
and then all those people will be in a
union who have a ton of voting power and
will say like you must fund us and the
potential back you got it you know will
guarantee it
and then they vote all the people will
vote for it to guarantee their you know
their jobs they don't want to they don't
to give it up
so I mean it's a sad reality of
capitalism that sometimes things become
obsolete and sometimes companies fail
mm-hmm yeah if we get rid of airtime
that's actually what Ron Paul's uh the
thing I was reading about was basically
about that he's like look it's it is a
scary virus but we're giving up our
liberties and the problem is it's gonna
be hard to get them back because the
government you know we're not gonna get
them back you give it up they're gone
because how do you convince when a
government takes it yeah they have no
reason to ever give it up at all right
so what do you do like when it comes to
the private sector you can negotiate
yeah and if they can't so the thing
about private
is that they have to convince you to
keep supporting them yeah think about
government is this come to your house
and threaten to lock you in a you know
concrete cell hmm and the knee or else
sounds like the CCP a little bit well
it's it's all just different forms of
authority yeah so that's the challenge
with giving the government too much
power what so so here's here's the funny
thing about all these socialists that
are cheering for this stuff right now is
look man monopolization of corporate
power is a dangerous thing you know but
it takes a really long time when you
have a CCP like you know the Communist
Party of China you snap your fingers and
communism and create an instant monopoly
with all that power they'll never give
it up we don't like the monopolies we
have now why would I take all of that
power from the corporations plus the
government and mash it into one 100
times bigger monopoly that makes no
sense
true yeah yeah what an exhausting
apocalypse I feel like this morning when
I woke up I was looking at a couple
stories I actually I was gonna record
something on like we now have three
states that aren't our national disaster
the National Guard is being deployed the
Army's being deployed and I started
reading these stories and I was like it
really feels like they copied and pasted
from a story from last week and just
dropped it in because the news is such
the same thing every single day now yeah
it's like the market fell again on
Monday and it fell by the I'm like did
you just copy and paste and I'm like
yeah place the numbers because these
stories are the exact same well now we
got the hold like Democrats so this is
well here's what's interesting about
ridiculous but here's what I find truly
interesting about is that you're not an
overly political guy none and that's all
you know about it yeah well but it's
funny to watch the the New York Times
change from you know Democrats ruin it
Democrats protect quarters and then
their bipartisanship is to blame and
then now it's now it's on hold and it's
Mitch McConnell's fault like that was
the new line it was like how did wait
what they first said you know the
Democrats did it and they said the
Democrats did it to protect workers then
I said oh it's partisanship no but
what's truly interesting about it is not
so much what's happening but that that's
the article from the hill that said damn
Kratz blocked the aid package right had
five it has like 500,000 shares not
views shares yeah Wow if each share it
you know if each person is sharing it to
a couple hundred people mm-hmm and at
any one time you know 15 to 20 will
actually see it we're looking at
millions upon millions of views on the
article saying the Democrats did this
yeah that's true and so I was reading
another article and it said you know
Mitch McConnell was was accusing
Democrats of trimming this a liberal
wishlist they accused him of a slush
fund guess which one doesn't work to the
American public the Democrats I don't
know what a slush fund is I don't I
don't know what the point they were
trying to make was yeah all I know is
that the Republicans skipped their
vacation and said we're gonna get this
bill done and then Nancy Pelosi came in
get back from vacation and said and
block it and then double the length of
it they said well you had all this stuff
in there it's really too much and then
it's twice as long with like all sorts
of new stuff in it that has nothing to
do with virus yeah it's a wish list so
here's the thing I've been waiting for
you to tell me that that thing is what
you I had a thing and yes oh and all the
regular people I am the thing everyone
cuz I've had either welcome I've had
friends say what do I don't understand
why the Democrats blocked us I need
money yeah and I'm like there you go
they don't know who Mitch McConnell is
right they don't care they heard the
word Democrat mmm-hmm they heard there
was $1,240 bi it's this is supposed to
be help us stay on our feet right now
and then and then a month we can do
another vote
yeah oh there we go yeah so I'll put it
this way if a dude walked up to you and
was like bro you want 1,200 bucks and
you were you'd be like yeah alright yeah
and that's what I have to do for it I'm
gonna give these 1,200 what are we gonna
have to do for it there's a rich guy in
a suit and he said I'm trying to help
everyone out by giving out twelve
hundred dollars to you and he reaches
out that money and then along comes
Nancy Pelosi and she smacks it
and the money goes flying who would you
be mad at Nancy Pelosi and she'd be like
you don't understand he was only gonna
give you that one time I was gonna give
you more like what she was sending me
money don't care yeah exactly
give me more later right yeah people are
stressing about it yes they need money
right now I saw a journalist from The
Huffington Post post on all caps people
have no money when it was when it came
out the Democrats were blocking the the
vote on it again yeah it's like and
we've talked about this like no one like
the average person in America can't
afford a $400 swing an emergency you
know and now it's like they don't have a
job they can't work so they don't have
any money so that like the extra 400
bucks is its long spent and there's
nothing coming in yeah they need money
right now oh I can tell you that I I
know a little bit about it like what
they were opposing and you know they
want it they want to have it based off
of your 2018 tax return and guess why
right it's if there's there's problems
with it but my response is like look man
I have friends who make minimum wage as
servers who barely get by yeah who are
hitting me up saying I don't know what
I'm gonna do yeah because they work on
tips right and it's like cash tips is
well no no that's the issue the issue is
that even with tips are getting like 10
bucks an hour right so so so they barely
they barely pay their rent yeah and then
while we're you know while this all
going on they're saying like my company
might lay me off and I was like well the
good news is Trump's about to cut you a
check for 20 bucks yeah and they were
awesome and then today they were like
what happened and I'm like asses hats
the Democrats man I don't they said they
didn't like it and it's look it's fair
if you want to criticize what was in the
bill and they got problems that all
right we'll talk about it but nobody
cares yeah my friends who make no money
and are like I'm trying to figure how to
get by pay my rent buy food and I just
heard that we're not getting that check
now and I'm like while the Republicans
skipped their vacation for well what if
the Democrats were saying you know what
look we're gonna have a provision in
this bill that nobody who but chugs gets
a piece of this nobody who licks toilets
is getting a piece of this I'd be like
you know what all right well maybe so
maybe one of the issues apparently is
that is that if you don't have any
income at all you get nothing but it
depends on so I was reading some
activist website that's what they
claimed okay
according Axios the minimum is 600 bucks
so I don't forget 600 bucks so I don't
know if I believe the activists because
they just screech all the time
okay but Axio said that if you don't
have the appropriate qualifying income
then you'll get $600 hmm if you have at
least 2,500 you get $1,200 and then
after 75 thousand a year it starts going
down a little bit and then at 95 if you
have a salary of 99 thousand or more you
get nothing but this is based on 2018 so
there were problems with the man but all
I know is like I was talking to a friend
of mine who said like I got to figure
out my tax return information it's like
I file for this or whatever and I was
like no no don't worry about it
and she was like what you mean don't
worry I'm don't worry about it the
Democrats killed the bill yeah you gotta
file anything anymore yeah so you're not
gonna have any money congratulations
you know somebody sent me a message
saying that a bunch of people are
commenting on you know Facebook about
how was the Republicans who blocked the
bill by trying to give corporations all
this money and it's like what do you
what do you think a bailout is like
would you think they were voting on yeah
you think they were voting on not giving
corporations money to sustain their
employees I don't understand yeah that's
messaging man the Democrats have come
out and called it a corporate slush fund
a bunt people started tweeting to get it
you know getting a trending and I'm like
you realize corporations spend money
right and you know they like they employ
people I mean there's there's real
concerns of stock buybacks another you
know mother BS sure but these companies
are gonna go under and these are the
companies that Boeing just shut down
seventy thousand people are risking was
in there now it's like dude Great
Depression here we come you don't I
think mmm I think the Democrats are like
at this point they're like the dude in
what was that movie were the guy he or I
don't know it was a guy but he rides the
nuclear bomb you like a cowboy
wasn't that dumb captain no dr. strange
not strange love dr. strange kind of I
kind I kind of feel like it's that's
like the Democrats I've realized it's
all over they've lost Biden oh man oh
yeah he's just muttering and mumbling
nowhere to be found and they're just
like they just jumped on the bomb is I
going like burn it down baby we're going
down taking y'all with a
like they can't win yeah so they're just
like screw it
yeah light it up well little suicide it
does kind of feel like that doesn't it
yeah yeah all I know is I want to go out
I want to go to the movies me too I want
to go to the mall I we can't do it and
so I'll tell you what's making me angry
it makes me angry when morons lick
toilets and go party at the beach
apparently like in Florida to a bunch of
boats and they jammed them all together
and then a bunch people were like
chillin on the boats partying and so now
they're shutting down the marina it's
like you see right now we can walk our
dogs but if a bunch of morons go around
licking dog but then we're not going to
the Walker dogs anymore
so you you have the government said the
Marine is open they're like y'all do
your thing just don't you know social
distance yeah so they have a stay at
home stay at home order but you can go
on your boat right and then a bunch of
morons were like let's put all our boats
together have a party and the government
was like not shut down and California
shut down the beaches in the parks good
you know they keep going on right what
people were able to go hiking yeah by
yourself right good I'm gonna walking
through the woods I got a little stick
and then a bunch of [ __ ] set up the
party and they're like shut it down now
now I can't go walk through the woods by
myself it should just be like a no
partying rule cuz it's clearly like a
certain group of people that go out and
party that was a rule and so when the
cops show up and there's 10,000 people
down the beach what do they do they
can't arrest them all and brain hurt
here's the people out there here's the
best part
you don't happen in Hawaii oh gosh what
they shut the beaches down you know
people did what they just wanted the
beach anyway nothing you can do min
people are refusing to it to adhere to
any of this stuff so now I'm just like
dude at a certain point you know there's
gonna be people say I've been quarantine
for how long and these people are out
partying and chugging off butts yeah
resent out I'm not doing this anymore
yeah they're gonna go out right and then
a certain point the only reason this
lockdown happens is because people
agreed to it that's true if at any point
people said nah no net confidence in the
system there would be no lockdown nobody
would care you can't do anything about
it and there's too many people it's like
what do you do arrest everybody no we're
just trying to go about their day dude
with several hundred but chuggers ow
the beach plus thousands of people
partying mm-hmm how many people do you
think are sitting at home right now
feeling for one FOMO like like oh dude I
miss the butt chug party man ah dude why
did I stay I want to go out I think that
specific numbers quite low wish that
they could but chug yeah yeah I thank
God that numbers someone else out there
someone out there is like I but Chuck at
home haha the roommate come over yo Dave
come over your budget
let's go chug come on you know you don't
you thanks for checking out this clip
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show live Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. if you want to catch the full show
tune in to this channel subscribe hit
the like button or check us out on
iTunes and Spotify and we will soon have
this podcast up for free on all podcast
platforms thanks for hanging out and
we'll see you all in the next episode
you